will filmmakers make more money from
Netflix or 2B so it depends on the film
Netflix mostly pays license fees for
films straight payments and here's what
will you know pay you for your film and
we'll get it for this length of time and
that's it
um two we can do that too now they have
paid
um upfront monies
um but Toby mostly works with
distributors
so like I don't I don't pitch to be
because I just don't find they're really
that interested in taking on
true Independent films directly from
filmmakers or from reps
um
so they're more part of the mix with
what the Distributors doing at the end
of the day and so most films most true
Indies are not getting the Netflix deal
but getting on 2B
so they're making more money by default
from 2B on their films if they were to
get it if if they if Netflix did buy the
film and then eventually it got on 2B
um
it could be that it could be that the
Netflix deal was so good that they'll
never make as much money on 2B as they
did for that deal or it could be a small
license fee and then it takes off on 2B
because it's the right kind of content
for 2B
um so yeah it just kind of depends it's
not really a very uh straightforward
um answer to that really
working filmmakers go to make the most
money on their films so I would say
the in general
[Music]
most people are going to make the most
money through all rights Distributors to
handle all these various platforms and
maximize all the platforms as best they
can for the filmmaker
um
you know ideally you get a big fat
license fee from a streamer
um
ideally you get a lot or ideally you get
a large minimum guarantee a payment up
front from your distributor to handle
the rights which they'll recoup from
revenues later
um but that doesn't happen for most
movies
um so and most movies don't get the
direct to streaming deal so most movies
get the All rights distribution digital
and sales deals that are out there
and for me
unless you want to put on the hat of
self-distribution for six months to a
year
and you have the right kind of film for
self-distribution
the path of going that way with an all
rights distributor is the best way to go
on the other hand if you've made a
documentary
about
dogs
and you have
great contacts with
organizations that are devoted to dogs
saving dogs rescue organizations
lovers of dogs on in social media groups
and you've cultivated over that time or
you're willing to go and cultivate that
and there are
there are people out there that can help
you do that there's a couple of great
you know kind of self-distribution gurus
out there that are great at teaching you
how to
maximize the that the value out of that
kind of film
um and there have been a couple
filmmakers I said well you've got the
kind of film you should probably do that
with
rather than going through me and trying
to get traditional distribution
um but for the most part if you've made
a comedy drama Thriller horror or family
film
a narrative film or a documentary that
doesn't have a knee like that kind of
Niche that you and and you don't have a
self-distribution hat that you want to
put on self-devision is not the thing to
do like it's a overwhelming undertaking
and it's and it's got its own risk is
not foolproof you can go out there and
do all those things those
self-distribution things and it not work
as well but as long as you're happy with
that and that's the thing you want to do
that that could be the option for some
some filmmakers but overwhelmingly most
people are going to maximize the value
of their film by going into an all
rights distributor that handles all the
various rights
what if you have a Christmas film or a
women in Peril slash women in power
whatever they're called now
so
um
so there's lots of there's lots of
options for both of those genres
um kind of depends on the quality of the
film and how it comes out
um but the
uh both of those are in demand
internationally
um both of those you have to sell it at
the right time of year though because
you need a long lead time like most
Christmas films
um are released in November
um to be released in November you have
to made your deal with someone by you
know August or so
so the best time to sell I mean truly
the best time to sell a Christmas film
is probably May
um because then you're giving your
distributor a lot of time to really get
everything going and geared up properly
for that release in November
um
but you see Christmas films on Netflix
and on
all the different streamers and
theatrical and you know it's definitely
if you pull it off it's uh
it's it's definitely
um
I think there's lower like there's a
margin for error there there isn't with
other films same with well I think women
in Peril Thrillers there's also a margin
of error there like you can the film
doesn't have to be quite as good in
order to make money because it's a such
desired genre
and that's overseas as well as domestic
yeah oh wow for both of those
interesting what is the
self-distribution Hat just in a nutshell
what what is that
so
[Music]
um
there are different methodologies that
different people teach on on how to
self-distribute a movie
um and that usually
involves trying to identify groups out
there that would have natural
inclination to dig your film
and then whether it's going whether it's
going after those people on social media
directly and trying to Market directly
to them
or it's creating Partnerships with
organizations that have the same cause
and doing free screenings with those
people in order to create word of mouth
and then sell to their you know have
them in exchange for doing a free
screening they Market to their the the
larger group of people in their
organization
um
that's the way I've seen a couple of
people what a couple of
self-distribution gurus
um teaching these days in terms of
techniques to try to
um but it takes a lot of time and effort
and it's a different mindset you know
that a lot of film most of my filmmakers
like okay I'm done with my job I want to
distribute or distribute the movie
um and don't have the and don't want to
spend six months to they want to they
want that movie to get out and make
money and they want to get under they
want to be creative and make the next
project and they don't have that you
know salesmanship marketing
and you really got to get after it I
mean in order to make it work it's not
as easy as like finding a group on dog
lovers on social media and then just
send them a message you got to really
engage with them and get them and
connect with them and over time
um make yourself well known to them and
and become a part of that culture almost
in order to do that kind of
self-distribution there are a couple
anomalies of filmmakers that
managed to get some money in order to
help do their own self-distribution of a
non-documentary film where it was a a
comedy or a thriller
but usually it took it when they did it
they managed to pre-sell they they had
someone that pre-sold rights to a
foreign territory and they took that
money or they got money from some a
Sundance or some company entity that was
just wanting to support them and they
poured that money into a theatrical
release
and either they booked the theater
themselves and figured out how to do
that or they hired a Booker and then
then perhaps they really most of them do
end up doing a deal with a distributor
though at that point they handle all the
various digital rights rather than going
through an aggregator so most
most successful self-distribution of
non-documentaries that I've seen have
been pretty well funded to do a
theatrical and that helped the overall
picture of the film